muy sencillo hablar del arte en la
frontera cómo explicarlo como cómo poder
definirlo no es algo
que un poquito ahorita vamos a ver cómo
esto tengo que mostrar
aquí hay unos segunditos
y bueno previo a esto
una de las cosas que me puse a pensar al
momento de decir voy a hablar del arte
en la frontera como generalizar a algo
así tan fuerte y lo primero que se me
vino pues mi vecino no te has puesto a
pensar que sería que tu vecino se fuera
a vivir a tu casa es como que hay
si de por si convivir con un vecino es
complicado ahora el estar todo el tiempo
con él pues es más no y eso fue lo que
me hizo investigar un poquito más de que
singul y que simboliza estar
aquí ya lo tengo
este estar en este punto no como méxico
eeuu súper importante de ahí me fui a la
base que dije bueno el arte chicano como
como influido en esta parte de d
no lo puedo cambiar
a esta el movimiento de arte chicano
porque como funcionó como como nació más
que nada y es precisamente eso eso que
les menciono de que básicamente el
mexicano vivía ahí acuérdense que era
territorio de méxico perdimos la mitad y
que ya es eeuu no entonces el chicano
nace a partir de estar en una raíz que
ahora ya se convierte en otra en otra
cultura eeuu entonces para él fue muy
fuerte la raíz es un motor muy muy
fuerte que tenemos como mexicanos y me
encanta decir eso como mexicanos porque
ese movimiento nos crea este
no va a ser así como que le saben porque
es surge y provoca una expresión
artística que es lo que hacemos como
artistas tratamos de ver de qué manera
podemos expresar alguna idea o ideología
que nos parezca o no nos parezcan y esa
es la forma que nosotros lo hacemos por
medio del arte que este es un movimiento
más grande en las calles desde los años
60 pero ya cuando empiezas a verlo todo
el rollo
este empiezas a comprender la
importancia que han tenido estos
artistas en todo el mundo
eloy cómo definirlo hoy hoy es muy un
tema muy crítico de hecho esa residencia
que le estaba platicando ahorita luz
elena es una residencia que le dice aquí
en landers california y la hice con una
americana un estadounidense totalmente
raíz de raíz
realmente era una descripción que nos
dijeron que yo veía las curvas ella veía
los las líneas esta descripción es como
muy ande no no me percataba pero ya
cuando te das cuenta la cantidad de
latinos que existen ahí en eeuu es
gigante y de esos seis americanos uno
tiene raíz latina pero el 63% viene con
raíz mexicana es algo muy muy fuerte de
hecho ella me dijo a yo sí sé hablar
español
sí sí hola muchas gracias
pero la temática ha cambiado en estos
tiempos por eso lo manejo como uno ya
antes era muy político se podría decir
no nos pensaba no pensamos tanto en lo
que es ahora el consumismo el medio
ambiente es un tema importantísimo
ahorita en estos tiempos la política
siempre va a estar pero para mí el tema
de migración es algo muy fuerte es un
tema que nos ha
globalizado y nos hace crecer el arte ya
puede trasladarse gracias a la
tecnología de una forma inmediata ya que
ya poder este tener contacto por medio
del internet
vamos a seguir y conectas por todo el
mundo
ok pero cuál es mi perspectiva cuando
empiezo a pensar en todo este tema de
del arte en la frontera como lo puedo
definir cómo puedo definir que mi
cultura es mexicana del norte entonces
de ahí empiezo a investigar un poquito
cómo
quién es marco miranda cómo nace
nace una mueblería no en un hospital y
me encanta decir esto porque yo cuando
entro a esta mueblería pues recién
saliendo de la universidad
marco antonio pérez miranda ay tuve mi
primer aprendizaje pero fue gracias a
una administración fue gracias a poder
salir
y comprendes que existe aunque somos
mexicanos existe un mundo diferente en
cada estado en cada ciudad es distinta
tú puedes ver ahora yo lo puedo definir
con movimientos más o menos no por
ciudades
el aprendizaje que he tenido en ese
punto de ensenada fue gigante fue mucho
más allá de lo que yo yo yo pensé que
pudiera hacer
porque uno nunca sabe en qué punto o en
qué momento va a crecer o va a brincar
oa hacer esto uno siempre dice no es que
yo quiero hacerlo es que yo lo estudie
pero la escuela no nos da muchas cosas
de ahí es cuando digo que el que el
oficio
otro más
el oficio es muy importante
luego hacer una pregunta más con un
aplauso es un sí con dos aplausos es un
no
alguien tiene idea o ha trabajado con
carpintería
ok 1 y 2 no vamos a empezar primero con
los 6 han trabajado con carpintería
ahora los dos
pero si una vez entonces se
contradijeron pague ok pues yo no había
trabajado con eso aunque en la escuela
te enseñan vez cómo hacer pintura como
ser escultura o les aseguro que muchos
de nosotros no tenemos un taladro en la
casa y eso es básico
yo lo digo porque entonces trabajamos o
no pero más que nada lo que me enseñó
fue a conocer qué madera o qué producto
es el bueno y eso es algo muy importante
en nuestra carrera saber
saber este
qué cuál de estas maderas es la mejor la
que no se va encorvar yo recuerden yo
estaba en ensenada a ya la humedad
afecta mucho los materiales sepan de
anne los cuadros y todo esto entonces
tienes que utilizar más calidad
y cuando estoy trabajando con esto
empieza a platicar ahora con el
eléctrico yo veo que está instalando
unas lámparas que me encantaban y mi
hijo no pensando tú yo no eso se me dice
no es muy sencillo nada más tienes que
juntar los cables es lo verde es uno
negro y el blanco en la tierra pero si
los agarró mal pues no va a quedar
pegado
pero todo eso lo tienes que hacer de una
u otra forma porque acuérdense yo no
estaba en mi casa me mudé y estaba
aprendiendo en mi casa empecé a hacer
esos vinos
ahora lo que se me entreno bastante fue
el ojo
repito no tenía experiencia nadie sale
con experiencia nadie sabe dónde va
exactamente pero fue parte del
aprendizaje
ahora nunca nunca pensé que dependiendo
de cómo acomodarse ese sillón esos
cojines es lo que el cliente va a ver y
va a decir sí sí me lo llevo acuérdense
que estaba en la mueblería y me tocaba
vender
de ahí me dice no te tengo aquí para que
seas todo todo el tiempo un vendedor
como voy a desperdiciar un licenciado en
artes en esto estoy hablando de esto
hace 15 años y 15 años nadie hablaba del
arte como lo hablamos hoy porque porque
no existía esa red de comunicación ahí
ya dejó de ser marco antonio pérez
miranda me dice tú tienes que ser marco
miranda directamente me dice ya no
tienes que ser una persona que anda aquí
que anda ya tienes que enfocarte en el
arte se fue un primer gran aprendizaje
que tuve
y de ahí convierto mi firma y ya me
empieza a entender cómo es el tema este
y comienzan el trabajo de alianzas
eso duró un poco tiempo duró un año de
ahí me
me salgo de esa mueblería
porque ya no concordaba en ideas
pero qué pasa sigo metido con el medio
del arte
ahora me meto unos campamentos de artes
a organizar y ahí es donde comienza otra
red comienza a juntarse una comunidad de
artistas que vive en los ángeles pero
que venían a trabajar que iban a
trabajar en sanar año tocada entrar en
el rollo de logística conseguir
patrocinios ta ta ta ta ta ta acuérdense
que hace 15 años no estaban las redes
que tenemos hoy no era tan sencillo como
te mando un whatsapp te mando un
facebook de algo esto te hago el otro
de hecho se hizo una convocatoria y la
única ciudad de baja que no participó
fue musical es un dato muy curioso pero
es por lo que les explico no vamos a
darle un poquito más y rey y regresó a
los ángeles ese punto para mí ha sido
muy fuerte lo que vamos a continuar le
aquí
de ahí hacemos el campamento nos va
súper bien conozco a gente de todos
lados
conozco a mi gran amiga argentina marisa
acá y yo lo que ahora es mi gran mentor
ahora yo siempre la visualizo como mi
coach aparte de amistad y me dice sabes
que si vas bien vas mal vas por acá no
te pierdas es como una guía yo creo que
cada uno tiene un guía muy importante en
profesión alguien que confías
y ella lo ha sido entonces cuando me
mudo acá mexicalli curiosamente después
de los campamentos pasó eso yo me estoy
yendo a un lugar que desconozco
pero ahí es cuando vamos a darle otro
más me topo con ese tema las empresas
llegó aquí el 2006
y el primer lugar que entro es a la
universidad al agua abc por lo mismo y
le repito no había licenciado en artes o
muchos licenciados en artes en ese
tiempo y qué es lo que pasa diego dejo
mi currículum porque yo iba a venir a
hacer un mural temporal y me iba a
regresar al día siguiente ella me habla
el director y mi hijo marco que tengo un
tiempo completo que posibilidad había de
tener un tiempo completo yo no estaba
acostumbrado a trabajar con algo seguro
no por verlo de una manera seguro
toda esa historia fue de gran
apertura mental
porque mi docencia se amplió era docente
pero al mismo tiempo era museógrafo
y no dejaba de pintar entonces estaba
diversificado también
en ese tiempo tenía 22 6 27 años
pero
no más puede estar cinco años allí
qué sucede políticas de la universidad
te exige en cierto tiempo no entonces yo
no podía estar mucho tiempo ahí y la
cosa es que me voy porque necesito
viajar comienzo a viajar estos viajes me
llevaron al premio que mencionaron pero
de ahí me conecta algo muy importante
empresas mencionó que en word porque fue
la primera que me dé una gran
oportunidad quien fue la que me dijo
sabes que va queremos presentarnos a
nivel nacional en este panorama
en guadalajara una expo grandes y fue
con arte
el impacto fue gigante
de ahí
me mudo yo sigo trabajando y sigo
trabajando con otras empresas
ya se descompuso chamaco
pero qué es lo que pasa sucede algo
interesante comprendo cómo es el punto
de vista de una empresa que no solamente
es la imagen de la tecnología de la
empresa sino que yo tengo que crear una
por eso me divide en tres uno fue la
obra dos el arte empresa que éste me lo
mencionó como arte empresa como si
pudiera ser como corporativo el trabajo
que hago para ellos tres arte y diseño
de la obra
esto es lo que más me gusta hacer el
trabajo de
vamos a darle
vélez dando tu tranquilo tour aleja es
que son varias piezas pero yo me enfoque
mucho en la abstracción cómo generar a
través de la nada crear una imagen
después me transfiera a la calle y
ahorita estado trabajando más como un
movimiento que tiene que ser un difusor
pues no pero eso es parte del trabajo
que ha estado trabajo haciendo a lo
largo
ahora de lo que es lo corporativo lo
mencionado es esto
fueron piezas gigantes que se pusieron
pero le digo es que no es simplemente el
poner algo y que se vaya que lo tires a
la basura que es un caso de las
impresiones la idea es que sea algo que
se haga y se pueda guardar y se pueda
mostrar después como un testimonio
lo mismo pasa con otras empresas con
furukawa que se entrega un premio
[Música]
por aniversario se entrega un
reconocimiento a los directivos de las
empresas que están aquí en mexicali ojo
sigo hablando de las empresas y cómo
fusionar el arte y si pasa lo mismo con
otras es es un trabajo en cómo mezclar
el arte en esta zona y que me siga
generando ingresos sin que me afecta en
mi obra no
bajar la calidad de la obra la obra es
mía y la obra en la que se mueven los
museos y esto pero este es otro tema
ahora cómo fusionar lo de la otra forma
porque crear una una
arte y diseño
todo nació por esas tasas por unos
obsequios que le dio unos amigos me
pidió hay dame un as para vender y de
ahí se cree un mercado que no me
esperaba ese mercado me fue llevando a
ese punto
vamos a darle
fueron tazas lámparas ahora después
sillas después es la ropa y empiezo a
trabajar
empiezo a trabajar más con eso
ok ves hasta ahí porque porque en la
siguiente ya muestro méxico otra vez
porque pasa lo que me doy cuenta
políticamente
nos damos
a cómo nos ha afectado la conexión
tecnológica en este aspecto todo eso
viene a partir
de la revolución industrial lo que antes
era un caballo ahora es medio de
transporte que es el automóvil o
cualquier otro medio
de ahí esto es nuestra nueva revolución
la conexión el internet
y conecta con todo el mundo
a través de nuestra nueva oficina móvil
y vamos a darle
por eso yo siempre he sentido que
vivimos en otro méxico
porque ya no necesitamos estar
conectados todo el tiempo estar
visitando sino que tenemos que salir
pero más que nada lo que mencionaban
ahorita vamos a desconectarnos para
vivir en tiempo real
y qué tan difícil es eso ahora es
complicadísimo
eso es lo que aprendí a ver ahora que
estuve ahí en la luna más y le ponemos
pausa
lo que vi ahora en la residencia
entonces
ya no por último les quiero decir algo
que tenemos nosotros como mexicanos lo
más grande que tenemos es tener una raíz
muy fuerte que nosotros sabemos que es
muy importante la familia escucharnos a
todos pero más que nada ser abiertos
que como creativos
nuestro nuestro único impedimento no es
él
nuestro único impedimento no es el que
nos pongan un muro ahí sino que nuestros
pensamientos es más fuerte entonces hay
que siempre buscar cómo atravesarlo con
ideas
y la otra
hay que recordar que la tecnología es
una herramienta y no olvidar lo que es
el ser humano y de ahí tan tan es muy
sencillo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]